okay this person is asking is it necessary for
character perfection to occur before receiving
the latter rain then then they say please
explain baptism of the holy spirit as it relates
to the latter rain what's the function of the
latter rain it cannot be understood unless you
understand the function of the early rain it is
based on the agricultural practices of people
in the east the world of the bible the early rain
came so that the seed can germinate and sprout and
life can begin the latterian came to bring it
to harvest this was taken by bible writers and
applied to the work of the holy spirit in the
church the great demonstration of the holy of
the light of the early reign was what happened at
pentecost the latter rain will bring that work to
full fruition now those who receive the light
rain will be those who've made the most of the
early reign having surrendered themselves entirely
to christ then christ can safely pour upon them
the latter rain so that they can go forward with
the loud cry of revelation 18 1-5 combined with
revelation 14 9-12 and present that message that
warns the world and prepares christ to come back
the lettering will be received by those who have
made the most of the early reign who even now are
continually searching their lives searching their
hearts am i right with god am i doing all i can
god sees them and by the spirit the very
spirit of god the only reign qualifies you
i should say to receive the latter in but many
of us do not even value or use the early reign
then we cannot receive the lottery the lateran
brings everything to full completion and to full
perfection and under the latter reign god's people
reached a point where they perfectly reflect the
character of jesus christ christ object lessons 69
paragraph the baptism of the holy spirit is merely
being filled with the holy ghost so that you
become empowered to take the word of god and to
preach the gospel and to reflect the character of
jesus christ the fundamental role of a christian
is to reflect jesus christ that is only done by
the indwelling of the spirit of god the latter
reign is a form of the spirit of god individually
before the latter lateran falls generally
some people receive it individually the same way
some people's probation close around us day by day
there's also a general closing of probation we
must use the lettering we have a knowledge of god
we have elon white we can reach steps to christ
we can read desire of ages what are we doing to
get close to christ now if nothing why should he
trust us to receive the latter the latter and when
it falls we would not even recognize it and we
would fight against it the lettering is the power
that brings everything to completion and it will
be much more spectacular than what was done under
the early reign and the baptism of the spirit
is just that you have given yourself entirely
to christ you are led you are baptized into that
spirit by total submission and your life is led
by the spirit of god everyone who's saved would
have been somewhere baptized by the spirit of god
amen so you're not exemplifying the former rain
you can't expect a ladder no you can't separate
them forget the lighter rain and let me rush off
to the early forget the early rain let me rush off
you can't skip steps there are two latter early
latter one goes with the other and i and i guess
we can't take it upon ourselves to feel like
we're filled with the spirit and go on our own
in the new christian church in acts god
asked them to wait they had to wait and
they got together they were of one accord
in one place unity among the brethren is
essential for the downpour of the latter
in unity among the brethren differences put
aside
you